issues losing weight dr nash has the
solution she has been
transforming lives across the valley
take a look at vito's incredible results
on dr nash's program i lost 170 pounds
and this is the result dr nash every
time i see the video of vito it gets me
it just gets me
170 pounds 38 pan sizes
his results are unbelievable yeah they
really really are like it is crazy so
commonly i'll get asked you know is your
program just for women we always see you
talking about a lot of women when you
when you talk about your show so i
always like to bring veto because it
shows one that men can do it too
and two the results are amazing
when you actually go after the damage
that's driving the weight loss in the
first place
let's talk about you too because you not
only show people how to lose this weight
how to transform their bodies
you've done it yourself let's talk about
your results
yeah i mean i literally my program is
literally a creation of frustration is
what i like to call it because
i was somebody that struggled with
obesity for 25 years
since i was eight years old desperately
trying to just be a normal weight and
hold it and could never find anything
that worked so
in 2009 when i started investigating my
own problem i found that there's these
underlying issues that literally
sabotage your weight loss make it where
you can't lose it
when i did that i lost the 80 pounds
like we all know but more important than
that reverse the conditions reverse the
damage
and now can eat two to three thousand
calories a day and maintain that weight
loss and
that's that's freedom chase well you
look you look beautiful
you look gorgeous and today we're
talking about something
um it's called candida and candida is
something that
affects your immune system and prevents
a lot of people from losing weight tell
us more about it
yeah candida is short for candida
albicans it's actually a yeast or a
fungus that we're supposed to have in
trace amounts in our large intestine
but when it overgrows and goes
throughout the body
not only can it cause toxicity not only
is it related to beating up your immune
system but it can cause a weight gain of
32 pounds
in one year because these are literally
little bugs living in your body
and they're driving your hunger your
appetite and your cravings it's crazy
little bugs living inside your body we
gotta we gotta fix this
yeah right you don't you don't want any
squatters right
no you don't no you don't so okay
someone's watching this right now
how can they tell if they have candida
is there tests we can do
yeah there is the problem is the
symptoms sound like symptoms of a whole
host of other things so the best way is
to do a test you can do it right at home
in the privacy of your own house first
thing in the morning
before you eat or drink anything deposit
some of your saliva into a clear glass
of water if you see a white
film dropping down within 60 or 90
seconds
that's the bugs that's the literal yeast
coming out of your saliva into the water
it means you have an overgrowth and it
means you need to get it corrected
yeah so what is the special exact
special we have for us today
yeah so normally the evaluation to
figure out what's going on with a
stubborn problem is about 97
but if people mention that they saw me
on las vegas now with jc then i'm gonna
offer it for 9.97 so less than ten
dollars
to find out if you have this problem and
even better if you can reverse it lose
the weight for good and move on
there's more las vegas now just ahead we
will be
right